have you been to a meeting no never no
you were a cocktail party later you
found out
i'm not a communist i've never been a
communist but technically yeah i am
radio broadcast walter winchell's show
casually says at the end of the show
that america's most popular female
television star was a member of the
communist party and then
also desi's picture being on the cover
of confidential magazine with another
woman and the headline desi's wild night
out and that's when uh all hell broke
loose
and it certainly looked like
that was gonna be the end of i love lucy
we've been through worse than this
we have no
that's what i thought
the more i got to understand her and see
what she was up against and see the way
in which she navigated this journey of
career and life and love when she was
accused of being a communist i mean
literally it was like that was all going
to be taken from her you know i did this
show so desi and i could be together i
had no idea i was going to be a hit i
just thought wow the construction
department's going to build us a little
apartment and that's where we'll live
most of the time and it worked out so
she has him and she has the show she has
the kids she's got everything she's the
most successful
female entertainer in the world
and feels like it could slip away like
that it's like a story you'd read a
little girl a witch puts a curse on a
woman she'll be adored by the man she
loves but only as long as she stays on
this
well there was one thing called 106.
it's one of my favorite scenes in the
script such a great scene that aaron
wrote it's a brilliant scene
but it was a powerful one that's one of
the scenes that you read on the script
and you read it and read it and you go
that's a great written scene now how the
hell am i going to do that because this
is the evening edition headline in the
hello express
desi comes up with this idea of just
meeting it head on and and getting it
out of the way and lucy's not so sure
this is going to work but does he's
attitudes i'm going to just put it out
there before the show and
let's say we want to know sir
does the fbi have any case against lucy
does the fbi have any
evidence of wrongdoing
does the fbi have any reason to believe
that lucille ball
is a communist
no absolutely nothing she's 100 clear
thank you sir one more question will you
tell us your name please this is jay
edgar hoover
thank you sir enjoy your event and right
after the moment that she's exonerated
by none other than j edgar hoover we
find out that the thing that she has
been worried about all week has not been
walter winchell the communist thing it's
been designed
[Applause]
they have this scene it i mean it comes
right on the crest of uh of this
triumphant moment and it really takes us
uh uh by surprise we did not know that
this right hook was coming
so enjoy
desi
has just uh cleared lucy in front of the
audience taking that risk and gamble
they reunite behind the set right
backstage right behind the the ricardo's
kitchen and in the seconds before the
show is about to begin i can remember
very specifically it being jeff cronin
with
who took me to that spot uh on our set
and said look i think we should do this
lucy desi moment here
here's where we can put the camera
they've just gone on this enormous
emotional roller coaster it seems like
they're in the clear now you want to
hear the crowd you want to hear the
tension building the show the
anticipation of the show to start
so it was close enough to to the
audience they get slightly out of sight
so the so they can't see this moment so
it's behind the main set the i love lucy
living room and kitchen set we had not
designated area where makeup mirrors
were and so
that became an interesting thing we had
done it earlier where we brought desi in
on a steady cam shot for another scene
103 and so we stacked the makeup mirrors
along there and that's a beautiful
source of light
thank you it's over no thank you he's
pulled a rabbit out of a hat
and he's done it for her they love you i
love you
no one's gonna mess with you ever lucy i
thought they were going to boo
unfortunately desi is flandering and
drinking you know he was a real ladies
man he didn't love them the way he loved
lucy
but this was part of his issue and it's
really what was one of the main things
that broke them apart you want to do a
show have you been cheating on me
what have you been cheating on me is
this a bit no
no i haven't been when you stay out all
night you're on the boat playing carts
yes you haven't been with anybody else
what's going on with you honey don't
gaslight me desi has been denying
throughout the film that that story that
was on the cover of confidential
magazine desi's wild night out uh desi
has been denying that any of that
was true it was just a tabloid they just
made it up where did this come from i
mean they just cheered for you out there
they got it right didn't they who's it
they only got the picture wrong
did they get it right
did they get it exactly right jesus
christ i just proved out there that the
early express got it wrong you think
confidential magazine confit we're about
to go show
tell me what you think other than that
garbage tell me why you think i've
cheated on you
for a little while now we find out in
this scene
lucy has had proof that the story was in
fact true
and
she's sitting on the knowledge
that he's unfaithful that he's been
sleeping with other women it's like the
adrenaline and the joy collides with
i'm gonna have to leave you
that is your lipstick
remember you kissed me at the beginning
of the week and then took my
handkerchief and wiped the lipstick off
and put it back in my pocket and you
said you've never done that before i
hadn't then what the hell are we talking
about
this is my lipstick
when we think that we've achieved
the end of the road then there's an
expected
turnaround
for both of us for lucy and desi a
dramatic one one that is gonna change
their lives forever and that moment has
to be performed it's written
and
you can't really go there and unless you
really go there
they were
just call girls
they're hookers
we wanted the love that these two people
have to to bleed through no matter what
um
and all of their
flaws all of the things they that they
do that hurt each other
and yet they still love each other
and yet she's still gonna leave him
[Music]
it doesn't mean anything lucy
it just breaks your heart
and
she had to leave him
because that was her dignity and that
was her integrity the first thing you
need is that dialogue that dialogue is
amazing
second thing you need is a partner
nicole was amazing
and the third thing you need is a
director aaron was great in leading us
the room to explore
and the fourth thing you need is a lot
of luck
pray and just jump into it and we both
jump into it
[Music]
let's do the show yeah let's just forget
about this for a half hour yeah let's do
the show
jim
let's go
it's not gonna get better than this copy
that all right it was important to be
with each other nicole and i she's a
great colleague she helped me
i had her
holding back and we get into the pain of
it because it was painful
their performances and the words that
they said
it was an emotion emotional sequence to
shoot and i looked around and there were
several crew members that had tears in
their eyes that uh reacted to it so i
think we won that one
instead of smacking him across the face
instead of bursting into tears instead
of walking off the set he confesses and
she kind of cuts them off and says let's
just do the show settle
and action she wants to get into that
living room so bad the ricardo's living
room that's where everything works
that's where you know ricky loves lucy
that's where it all works out lucy
i'm home and then at the very end when
he walks in and he says lucy i'm home
oh
[Music]
i read that and i went no way
aaron you did not manage to bring it
full circle like that
and he did and that's aaron spoken for
you and it sets you up for the last shot
which is lucy standing alone on the set
which was her safety her comfort area to
have
a home and it became the show and it
still didn't work and that's that was
the isolation sorry
i got lost for a second and then the
show begins as we
pull up and we're pulling up through
kind of the scaffolding above a sound
stage what the scaffolding is doing is
it's putting
box after box uh as we go up
around that living room so we end by
just putting the two of them in that
patch of ground
he could give her so many things
but he couldn't actually
be at home
only with her
[Music]
you